[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale avec tv
60,18 bienvenue dans cette édition tout
de suite les titres de ce lundi 11
février
les républicains en ordre de bataille à
trois mois des européennes de
représentants du parti de droite était
dans le département son président
laurent wauquiez en déplacement dans le
nord des yvelines et sa tête de liste
pour le scrutin françois xavier bellamy
le versailles était en meeting dans sa
ville c'est la journée internationale de
l'épilepsie ce trouble neurologique
touche 600 mille personnes en france
pourtant il est encore peu prise en
charge dans ce journal
le témoignage d'une mère et de son fils
épileptique habitant à saint rémy les
chevreuse et puis l'antenne est en place
depuis quelques mois sur le territoire
le collectif contre l'islamophobie
combat les actes de discriminations et
de violences contre les personnes et
institutions musulmanes
quelle est la situation dans les
yvelines mostefa la zunie membres du
collectif est notre invité nous recevons
également sur ce plateau pascal romano
directeur du conservatoire de plaisir
pour parler de la semaine de la guitare
qui se tient dans la ville
l'opération reconstruction se poursuit
donc pour le party les républicains à
vendredi dernier le président de la
formation laurent wauquiez est venue
dans le département
le soir la tête de liste aux européennes
françois xavier bellamy a tenu une
réunion publique à versailles les
détails de nicolas landry un invité de
marque pour la mission reconstruction de
la droite laurent wauquiez président du
parti les républicains un déplacement à
l'école idec d'aubergenville des
formations dans l'industrie et des
rencontres avec des étudiants et des
personnes en réinsertion professionnelle
là j'ai changé quelqu'un qui était au
rsa qui avait repris une formation pour
ensuite déboucher vers un emploi à la
fin il me dit le problème c'est que la
différence entre ce que je gagne en
travaillant et ce que je gagne en
restant chez moi n'est pas très
importante
bah ça c'est important de l'entente ce
déplacement dans les yvelines rentre
dans le cadre du tour de france engagée
par le président des républicains pour
recueillir les difficultés sur le
terrain et notamment dans ce bassin
industriel du nord du département un
territoire industriel qui subit de plein
fouet la concurrence internationale qui
se bat et qui veut rester un territoire
industriel et qui pour ce faire
des chefs d'entreprise des
établissements éducatifs comme celui là
qui participe à la compétitivité du
territoire mission reconstruction
également dans la soirée à versailles
autour de la tête de liste des
républicains aux élections européennes
françois xavier bellamy au début il ne
faisait pas l'unanimité dans son parti
aujourd'hui les républicains sont
derrière lui bien sûr j'échange avec
gérard larcher j'ai eu l'occasion de le
voir de passer beaucoup de temps avec
lui il m'a redit à quel point d'ailleurs
il avait confiance dans le fait que je
pouvais apporter quelque chose à cette
liste il croyait que je n'avais
peut-être pas le poids politique
suffisant pour pouvoir être en tête de
liste et après tout c'est vrai que c'est
un pari et je suis prêt maintenant à
remporter ce défi
au delà du trio composé de françois
xavier bellamy d'agnès evren et d'arnaud
danjean
les républicains veulent porter une
certaine vision de l'europe
il faut absolument redonner sens à
l'europe parce que nous avons besoin
d'europe dans la mondialisation
mais nous avons besoin d'une europe
efficace d'une europe qui puisse agir
concrètement au service de nos
concitoyens journée pour une europe de
projets en europe de coopération entre
les pays
la reconstruction passe par les
élections européennes le 26 mai prochain
un résultat pour confirmer la victoire
des républicains aux yvelinois lors des
sénatoriales en septembre 2010 est avec
cinq sièges sur six remportée une page
santé à présent elle est passée en phase
épidémique depuis la mi-janvier le la
grippe semble avoir atteint son pic en
ile de france une région tentés de rouge
comme vous le voyez sur cette carte du
réseau sentinelles dans certaines zones
la maladie est tout de même en déclin
pour terminer l'hiver sans être
contaminés quelques gestes simples se
laver les mains régulièrement avec du
savon ou utiliser une solution
hydroalcoolique par exemple pour les
personnes ayant déjà contracté le virus
éternuer dans son cou d'utiliser des
mouchoirs à usage unique et si possible
porter un masque jetable
ce lundi c'est la journée internationale
de l'épilepsie cette maladie se traduit
par une activité électrique anormale du
cerveau l'épilepsie qui est encore selon
les personnes et associations concernées
mal prises en charge en france
témoignage d'une maman et de son fils
atteint d'épilepsie recueillis par manon
varaldo l'épilepsie est un mal invisible
isabelle mais l'insee table
reçue que son fils théo souffrait
d'épilepsie à l'âge de 7 ans et demi
la cause une tumeur cérébrale c'est
alors le cri d'une maman pour toutes les
autres mamans
isabelle méline devient la
correspondante locale des yvelines de
l'association épilepsie france car
souvent les familles se retrouvent
isolés face à la maladie s'ajoutent
l'éloignement par manque de prise en
charge en ile-de-france des épileptiques
pour nos fils théo il a d'abord vécu à
l'hôpital ici à un but lyon pendant
trois ans et après il n'y avait plus
rien pour lui donc on a dû le mettre
dans un centre spécialisé pour
l'épilepsie en bretagne et suite à la
bretagne mais s'est retrouvé sur
toulouse mais c'est là qu'il a préparé
un bac professionnel en gestion
administration penser que ça aurait pu
aller mais l'épilepsie vraiment
difficile à livrer c'est pas possible
qu'il puisse continuer en vient de bien
nous le dira il faisait que c'est vite
heures par semaine mais malgré ça c'est
à l'allègement il ya encore des crises
qui sont trop présentes qu'il peut pas
suivre
il prend trop de retard on aurait aimé
faire différent mais c'est impossible de
faire ça en tout cas pour l'instant dans
les yvelines deuxième pathologies
neurologiques en france les médecins
traitent l'épilepsie mais pas les
répercussions sur la vie sociale des
malades
ce petit lieu est vraiment les
crissements tube ça m'empêche énormément
bah d'être vraiment actifs
du coup je m'endors concours très vite
donc les utiliser les activités ses
scoops vide une espèce de man que social
le combat n'est pas terminé pour la mère
et son fils ils se battent pour une
meilleure prise en charge de cette
maladie au sein de la société notamment
dans les écoles manon par aldo qui est
avec moi en plateau pour parler de
l'épilepsie bonsoir ans à quelques
conseils à rappeler en cette journée
internationale que faire en cas de
crises convulsives avec perte de
conscience maintenant
alors tout d'abord restés calmes placer
la personne en pls dès que c'est
possible
ls grégory position latérale de sécurité
éloigner tout ce qui peut blesser la
personne et laisser la crise se dérouler
maintenant les choses à ne pas faire
surtout ne tentez pas d'introduire les
doigts ou un objet dans la bouche ne
déplacerait pas la personne sauf en cas
de danger après la crise rester auprès
de la personne jusqu'à l'est totalement
récupéré rassurer la sans la toucher les
concerne pas faire qui se sont affichés
un dernier conseil a rappelé mme anne
ont aussi contactés de contacter pardon
les secours si la personne est victime
d'une nouvelle crise qui allait blesser
ou que la crise dure plus de cinq
minutes merci pour ces quelques conseils
c'est un phénomène préoccupant en france
les actes islamophobes sont toujours
aussi nombreux d'après le rapport du cci
eef le collectif contre l'islamophobie
en france 446 acte de ce type ont été
signalés en 2017 bonsoir mostefa la
johnny vous êtes membre de l'antenne des
yvelines du ccf une antenne qui est
actif depuis quelques mois sur le
département des yvelines déjà qu'est ce
qu'on entend par un acte homophobe
islamophobe et alors d'après la
définition du que donne deux ccf
on considère qu'un acte et islamophobe à
partir du moment où c'est un acte de
discrimination par la parole ou par une
violence à l'encontre d'une personne ou
d'une institution pour une appartenance
réelle ou supposée à l'islam alors ce
chiffre de 440 6 axes signalé en 2010
est en france et on recule par rapport
aux dernières statistiques du ccf en
2016 après beaucoup après beaucoup
d'actes islamophobes reste non signalé
c'est ça il n'y a ni ne seront pas
forcément signalé dans l'axé si vous
avez des personnes qui vont être
victimes mais qui vont se taire qu'ils
vont garder ça pour elle qui ne vont pas
avoir soit la possibilité soit le
courage de dénoncer ces actes là donc
c'est un phénomène aujourd'hui qui est
encore très présent en france
c'est un phénomène qui est effectivement
présent en france et notamment à cause
de la situation sécuritaire qu' un
arrangement un petit peu les choses et
bien il ya encore un amalgame qui est
fait sur sur cette situation
malheureusement ou heureusement oui
est-ce qu'on peut pas dire aussi qu'en
france il ya un certain sentiment de
défiance vis-à-vis alors non pas que de
la la religion musulmane mais aussi des
autres religions quand on voit les actes
qui ont été perpétrés dans des églises
yvelinoise des actes de dégradation ce
week-end les inscriptions aussi
homophobes qui ont été réalisées à paris
un sentiment de défiance vous avez
l'impression vis-à-vis dès religions
alors il y a un sentiment défiance
vis-à-vis dès religions il ya aussi une
crise patient qui est due à la situation
que traverse que traverse le pays et
d'ailleurs à ce titre là au niveau du
ccis
alors effectivement on existence
spécialiste dans la lutte contre
l'islamophobie mais en est solidaire de
toutes formes de lutte contre les
discriminations dont celle que vous vous
excitez racisme alors du coup quelles
sont les missions justement du ccf alors
les missions premières du ccfc
d'apporter une aide juridique et
psychologique il faut il faut insister
là dessus aussi parce que derrière un an
et est toujours un humain il ya toujours
une souffrance elles sont par principe
gratuite
parce qu'il ne faut absolument pas que
le côté économique puisse empêcher
quelqu'un de faire valoir ses droits
surtout que malheureusement 70% des
actes d'islamophobie s'en sont faits à
l'encontre de femmes voilées dans des
femmes qui sur le plan par exemple de
l'emploi ne sont pas forcément aussi
bien loti que que la leur leurs
concitoyennes et donc du coup il est il
est primordial pour nous que c'est ces
aides que ces assistances soit gratuite
donc envoyé d'un accompagnement
juridique on sait personnes victimes
d'actes islamophobes ne sont pas
forcément au courant de leurs droits
comment agir si elles sont elles sont
victimes de ces actes islamophobes
alors le premier réflexe bien c'est de
dénoncer cet acte là alors soit porté
plainte soit demander conseil au ccf à
travers son adresse donc ses contacts
aux bases islamophobie point de n'être
donc ça c'est le premier réflexe est
actuellement voilà très bien ensuite au
niveau du cc du ccf
on a des juristes professionnels qui
vont prendre en charge la demande de la
personne qui vont définir s'il s'agit
bien d'un acte d' islamophobie ou pas si
c'est un indice à vos phobies
il sera pris en charge par le ccf
sinon on va là dirigés vers vers l'est
les autorités compétentes
ensuite ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
le cci a agi d'abord et avant tout à
travers la médiation
donc on essaie de désamorcer un petit
peu on essaie de contacter les soirées
des personnes soit des institutions qui
ont été qui sont coupables de ces actes
là ça marche ça marche souvent
maintenant il ya des situations où on ne
peut pas faire autrement et puis à ce
moment là il ya une ville d'ys et
réalisation de la faire et vous l'avez
dit également un accompagnement
psychologique alors l'antenne des
yvelines et est en place depuis quelques
mois il y avait un vrai besoin dans le
département des yvelines alors alors
pour être clair les allah
l'antenne des yvelines n'a pas vocation
à stigmatiser mais il n'y a pas plus
d'actu l'islamophobie dans les yvelines
qu'ailleurs leur nature n'est pas
spécifique d'accord par contre il y
avait un besoin d'ancrer son action
localement
parce qu'être quand je vous ai dit il ya
souvent un côté humain qui est très
important donc être au contact être au
plus proche des victimes est quelque
chose de très important
et puis a aussi la possibilité de
pouvoir développer des actions locales
des actions pas seulement curatif des
actions préventives à travers par
exemple des conférences débats à travers
des des mises en situation d'autodéfense
juridique et d'autres actions qui vont
qui vont j'espère qu'ils vont revenir
non pas de situation particulière à
mettre en avant dans les yvelines vous
parliez des actions mises en place les
prochaines dans les prochaines semaines
quelles sont elles alors il ya déjà eu
une première action qui a été qui a été
organisée sous la forme d'une conférence
débat au cours de laquelle bon il ya eu
deux temps le premier c'est que le
responsable de l'antenne a informé un
petit peu les les citoyennes et citoyens
qui étaient présentes sur ce qu'elle
sait ses élèves sur la définition exacte
de ce qu'est l'islamophobie parce que
c'est un point très important
ensuite dans un deuxième temps il ya eu
un débat un échange pour connaître un
petit peu la façon avec laquelle cette
problématique et vécu le ressenti des
gens ce qui nous permet ensuite entre
guillemets de pouvoir développer des
outils adéquats pour leur permettre de
faire valoir leurs droits quand ils sont
dans une situation
l'islamophobie et surtout insisté sur le
fait qu'ils font remonter tout
tous ces actes là et enfin leur demander
d'être actif parce que si c'est quelque
chose de très important être actif à
travers
une adhésion à travers du bénévolat ou
tout simplement en informant le cci et
la fin traversions d'antennes locales ou
les chaînes nationales donc de vous
contacter via les liens qui sont
affichées durant cet entretien merci
mostefa l'aide d'une chose à gagner à
travailler sur ce plateau membres de
l'antenne à des yvelines du collectif
contre l'islamophobie en france
elle va permettre de désengorger les
centres villes de montesson et de
sartrouville le chantier de la voie
nouvelle de la rd 121 été officiellement
inaugurée vendredi financé par le
département et la région elle doit
améliorer la fluidité et la sécurité des
circulations
or ils iront après neuf ans de travaux
cette voie souterraine sera ouverte au
public le 18 février
elle fait partie des infrastructures du
chantier de la voie nouvelle de la route
départementale 121 à sartrouville et
monte son un projet d'envergure qui a
nécessité un investissement de 96,6
millions d'euros
c'est 4 km de voies nouvelles de
kilomètres devoir restructurer
c'est aussi des ouvrages en souterrain
qui passe sous les voies ferrées à
sartrouville
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de
très costaud
ces différentes routes vont permettre de
décongestionner les centres-villes de
montesson et de sartrouville tout en
améliorant le cadre de vie des riverains
ça va dégager toute la zone commerciale
dans le quartier dit de lasbordes
où l'essentiel des circulations passera
dans cette nouvelle voirie au lieu
d'encombrer toutes nos petites voirie
c'est une opportunité fabuleuse de
réduire la circulation dans notre ville
en organisant une voix particulière
notamment pour la circulation de transit
qui était abondante est très importante
dans tout le coeur de la ville de ses
retours de la région ile de france a
participé à ce chantier à hauteur de 6
millions d'euros dans le cadre du plan
régional anti bush ont trois kilomètres
de pistes cyclables ont également été
aménagés cette route que ce n'est pas
des aménagements urbains ça n'est pas de
la pollution ça n'est pas du bruit c'est
vraiment de la qualité d'unique pour les
habitants
les travaux de cette voie nouvelle
doivent s'achever en 2020 avec la mise
en service d'un dernier tronçon au sud
de l'autoroute a14 transport toujours le
tram 13 entre saint cyr l'école et
saint-germain-en-laye doit être mise en
service en 2021 son chantier prévoit des
coupes d'arbres et pour compenser ces
abattages trente mille arbres ont été
plantés en forêt de saint germain en
laye samedi une centaine de personnes a
mis en terre de jeune pousse de chêne et
des poiriers sauvages des plantations
sur 17 hectares situés notamment aux
abords du camp des loges
ils sont près de six cent soixante six
mille élèves français inscrits en lycée
professionnel une voix qui avait son
forum qui a son forme chaque année à
guyancourt à la dernière édition de ce
rendez-vous se dérouler vendredi 38
exposants établissement ou organisme de
formation sur place et des métiers
également représenté plus de 1200 jeunes
s'étaient inscrits à l'événement les
propos sont recueillis par patrick
jacques de dixmude
c'est un peu original parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de forums de l'orientation qui
existe dans beaucoup de villes mais
vraiment cette ce forum de la voie
professionnelle ça n'existe qu'ici à
guyancourt
je trouve ça très important parce que
ben ayant en charge effectivement ces
jeunes ça me permet de les retrouver
les années suivantes sur les formations
mais en même temps c'est très important
de leur présenter ce qui les attend à la
fois du côté des métiers des professions
des formations mais aussi des contenus
de formation et quels sont les parcours
et les réussites que l'on peut avoir en
arrière et c'est très important que l'on
montre notre savoir faire et nos
réussites que ça soit du côté des
diplômes des formations mais aussi de de
tous les réseaux que nous pouvons aussi
leur vraie culture à plaisir la ville
organise sa semaine de la guitare ça
débute ce mercredi et ce jusqu'au mardi
19 février jam session masterclass expos
et concerts sont au programme pour en
parler parce qu'elle romano bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur du
conservatoire de plaisir alors pourquoi
dédié une semaine à la guitare un
plaisir tout d'abord nous avons souhaité
mettre à l'honneur un instrument
extrêmement fort et représentés au sein
des différents conservatoires et
évidemment chez nous et nous avons
souhaité aussi avoir le privilège de
mettre un coup de projecteur sur la
venue d'un artiste un artiste vraiment
important pour la guitare qui emmanuel
rossfelder qui vient donc entre autres
dans un des temps forts de la semaine
faire un concert au théâtre espace
coluche l'un dès mercredi
ça c'est dès mercredi donc le concert a
lieu vendredi on peut le voir comme un
temps fort évidemment de ceux de cet
événement et mercredi il sera parmi nous
et de manière très simple avec un projet
vraiment accessible à tous qui s'inscrit
d'ailleurs dans la volonté de ce projet
qui qui peut être vu comme un nouveau
projet mais qui est plus la volonté de
là on peut dire la feuille de route un
petit peu que nous avons au niveau de la
ville de cette feuille de route culture
qui a été impulsée par le dab le maire
qui est de rendre accessible la culture
à tous et de la rendre maître de ne pas
la rendre
me dérange c'est pas de la vulgarisation
c'est plus de l'accession à quelque
chose d'un petit peu exceptionnel
centralisée plein d'événements autour de
cet événement ce gros évènement qu'est
la semaine un échange qui sera possible
d'échanger avec les mud rossfelder un
échange aussi pour les élèves du
conservatoire
un temps aussi pour les classer nos
différents élèves un beau concert donc
là qui est accessible ici aussi à tous
et puis ne pas oublier sur l'aspect
guitare les esthétiques aussi on a vous
parle du classique mais il ya le jazz et
nous avons voulu aussi donner mettre à
l'honneur un tout là toute la variété de
cet instrument
beaucoup de courants au sein de la
guitare et vous le disiez la guitare
qu'à une place importante au sein des
conservatoires c'est le cas à plaisir
c'est le cas plaisir nous avons deux
classes de professeurs qui ont un ce
qu'on peut appeler un temps plein donc
ça doit représenter une cinquantaine
d'élèves du plu delà de la première
année ou plus avancées et l'idée c'est
que tous ces élèves là puisque
évidemment avoir un temps sur cette
semaine ce qui sera le cas et la chance
pour le plus avancé justement d'avoir
une rencontre avec cette artiste qui est
un lien à la filière professionnelle et
à la vie de cet artiste français
plusieurs choses qui sont proposés des
jam sessions jam session des concerts
l'idée c'est de proposer plusieurs
formules sûr sur cette semaine la
guitare c'est de proposer plusieurs
formules de montrer plusieurs facettes
de la chose de montrer aussi un
caractère un petit peu on va dire un
clin d'oeil avec un collectif d'artistes
qui vient aussi faire une exposition sur
des guitares un petit peu customiser
dont voilà qui sont à découvrir c'est
très original
tout ça sur des lieux assez repéré le
mercredi nous serons sur le site du
château autour du théâtre robert manuel
a cours des communs avec emmanuel
rossfelder le vendredi nous serons
plutôt le projet se déplace au théâtre
espace coluche et le mardi
à la clé des champs pour la jam session
et l'aspect jazz delà de la guitare tout
programme est bien sûr à retrouver sur
le site de la ville de plaisir tirer
plaisir point fr et quels sont les
objectifs qu est ce qu il ferait que cet
événement soit soit une réussite pour
vous mais que chacun vienne chacun
découvre et chacun prenne plaisir
nous avons déjà beaucoup de monde
inscrit puisqu'il ya quelques
inscriptions à respecter car les places
sont limitées
et puis l'idée c'est de faire partager
de donner à tout le monde le l'occasion
de découvrir et d'échanger sur ce projet
merci pascal romano directeur du
conservatoire de plaisir et cette
semaine de la guitare c'est de mercredi
ça débute mercredi et c'est jusqu'au
mardi 19 février à plaisir une
transition parfaite entre la culture et
le sport elle fait partie des quatre
disciplines qui pourraient faire leur
entrée aux jo de 2024 le breakdance
peut-être et bientôt sport olympique une
proposition qui est en discussion en ce
moment et d'après nos confrères de
france info la danse a en tout cas été
intégrés et des l'an passé aux jeux
olympiques de la jeunesse à buenos aires
avec deux médailles françaises le
breakdance courant du hip hop dont une
compagnie saint-quentinoise a été
pionnière en france les black bomb les
blacks blancs beurs pardon écoutez la
réaction de son co fondateur jean gmat
qui émet quelques réserves
ça me suggéra un sentiment paradoxal
c'est que d'un côté
voilà une ultime reconnaissance d'un
savoir faire deux choses extrêmement et
du corps et complexes beau à voir et qui
devient un sport de compétition c'est à
dire qui affirme nettement linverse
finalement de ce qui l'a amené à se
développer comme un genre stylistique de
la danse hip hop à savoir une danse qui
porte un récit qui porte un
questionnement politique
un questionnement que culturelles et qui
a abandonné se positionne justement non
pas contre la compétition mais pose
d'abord
la compétition qu'on a à voir en nous
mêmes et non le principe d'être au
dessus des autres et cette décision
d'intégrer ou non le breakdance aux
jo-2000 24 à paris sera rendu dans le
courant du mois
[Musique]
vous les attendez chaque semaine avec
impatience les résultats sportifs du
week-end avec michael et demi d'euros
bonsoir bonsoir l'actualité sportive
toujours très chargé avec une météo
aussi capricieuse en ce week end michael
on commence avec du football c'est sa
direction le championnat de régionale 3
1 but a suffi à leur bonheur le strap
assuré l'essentiel ce dimanche 10
février en s'imposant sur la plus petite
des marges 1-0 à domicile face à pas
résident dans une rencontre marquée
ouailles but par des incidents
magnifique un magnifique jeu les vues
par les incidents en fin de partie les
conditions climatiques difficiles mettra
pas résisté à la tempête sur le terrain
on écoute les réactions micro de mélanie
pis on a réussi à développer un jeu
assez peu orthodoxes au monde y passe
que les terrains ne permettait pas trop
mais ça a été le but il nous a vraiment
libérés du coup après on a essayé de
poser la balle pour jouer un match
engagé puisque un terrain à la limite du
praticable mais un bon match dans
l'ensemble
on a su respecter les consignes qui
était donné et une victoire 1-0 qui me
semble mérité cette victoire était
également importante sur le plan
comptable grégory ce résultat permet à
trappes de conserver son avance sur son
adversaire du jour
c'est assez serré au niveau des points
c'est un concurrent direct c'est avec
cette victoire et on aimait à cinq
points derrière nous du coup ça nous
soulage et savoureux tira concurrents
pour le titre
à neuf journées de la fin du championnat
trap est toujours invaincu avec la
meilleure défense l'équipe pointe à la
deuxième place de régionale 3 après le
football du football américain
les templiers d'elancourt ont enregistré
leur troisième victoire en trois matches
dans le championnat de deuxième division
les élans courtois sur sont imposés
samedi soir à domicile face aux myrmidon
de savigny-le-temple le score 26 à 7 une
victoire qui leur permet de prendre la
tête de la poule b de la conférence nord
on écoute le président des templiers
d'elancourt joël da silva
trois matches trois victoires donc pour
l'instant on est dans net sur les
objectifs fixés qui est de se qualifier
dans un premier temps pour les play-offs
donc pour l'instant tout sans tous tout
s'emboîte correctement la semaine
prochaine on va villeneuve d'ascq payés
chez les vikings il donc
donc voilà pour l'heure son tour tout
est en ordre de marche et on termine par
du rugby dans le championnat honneur
versailles n'en finit plus de gagner 13
victoires en 13 matches pour les versets
qui se sont cette fois ci imposé dans la
douleur sur le terrain du rc paris 15 le
score 15 à 11 pour les joueurs de la
cité royale qui reste en tête du
classement avec écoutez moi bien grégory
à 21 points d'avancé sur le second
autant dire que la montée n'est plus
très loin mais beaucoup de points
d'avancé merci michael plus de résultats
de reportage à suivre dans l'émission le
7-8 force est à retrouver dans quelques
instants sur tv 60,18 voilà c'est la fin
de cette édition vous pouvez bien sûr
elle a retrouvé en replay sur notre site
internet belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]